yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby yeah
yeah how was youring weekend dude I went
to a circus oh that's right when the
last time I went to he goes well Brian
I'm at a circus and the uh the air
conditioning broke broke and now out
here in the valley it was about a hundo
about a hund and then we're at the
circus at 300 p.m. off toena and they
put it in the middle of a parking lot oh
that's a good time oh there you go 300
p.m. 3 p.m. now I was under the
impression cuz it's it's pumpkin season
so we go to all the pumpkin patches La
we do a lot of terrible things we
dominate in pumpkin patches you we have
the best in the straight up the best in
the world a lot of pumpkin pumpkins very
easy to grow by the way Jack of knights
right up the street off King R there
it's amazing you have uh that other Farm
up there I forget what it's called it's
the they're like the two best in the
United States they're like a mile apart
part yeah so I thought it was like a
Halloween thing M my kids love the
circus it was not cheap no it was not
cheap D I'm we sit down and I look at my
girl like oh this is like a circus she
go I said circus I'm like I thought it
was like Halloween no no no oh no and
that's a traveling circus now think
about this all family though it's a
family traveling circus so the guy who I
bought my nachos from was the same guy
riding around a motorcycle in the steel
cage with his wife in the middle what oh
yeah is a whole family excuse me what
yeah really I was stressed out the whole
time the whole time they cuz they bring
out like a a a circular cage and this
guy comes out a motorcycle like that's
cool he's just going to go up and down
in the motorcycle he starts doing that
and they're like let's add more and then
they bring in a girl his wife she's in
the middle like this he's going around a
million miles an hour I'm like geez
that's not safe yeah that's not safe
let's bring more another dude comes like
what the hell is going on here so two
I'm my stress is through the roof oh so
they're doing this I don't like this
already oh but imagine it's so it's
smaller than that they're going way
faster than that they turn the lights
off and then there's a there's a woman
in the middle then they bring in a third
guy you know when you're watching a
porno you're like there's no way this
going to fit it fits you're like oh
thank God now imagine a second big dunk
comes in you're like how are we going to
make this work they make it work now
imagine a third big black dick comes
like how are we going to figure this out
oh she navigated the waters dude I was I
just turned her into a into a the
filthiest of porn stars she's just a mom
oh yeah they're my favorite yeah
black.com shout them but then by the way
my fav but so then so then then there's
a steel if there is a porn thing I'm
going to I don't if there is but so then
then there's a there's a some sort of
weird thing it's like a metal bar
there's two balls at the end and these
two brothers get in there and it's so
hot spinning around they go outside of
it and they're flying in the air and in
my head I'm thinking how much are these
guys making yeah I know how much I paid
it's not that full I mean it was it's a
Thursday night at the cony Zone in
Charlotte you feel me it's not full okay
so I'm like I'm looking around like
there they're not making too much money
the rent here there's so many there's so
much staff with security all that and
I'm thinking it's not worth it fellas
it's not worth it want to say hey we're
entertained just stop yeah I'll just
stop I got my nachos the kids are happy
enough let's get out of here well were
there any animals in this circus it's
illegal so I was telling my son I said
when I was a kid so you don't put your
head there's no guy who tames Lions puts
his head in the L that's the kind of
cold hard cash I would pay for that's
the [__] I would pay I told my son I
said dude circus is so different when I
was a kid your grandpa shop took me to
the circus there were Lions there were
Tigers there're
elephantes he goes why did they stop
doing and chimpan I he he goes why did
they stop doing I said cuz that
elephante got sick of their [__] and
stomped all of them well did you ever
see the footage of the uh tigers that
were being tamed and a guy rides in on a
horse he's going to do horse tricks now
the problem with bringing a horse in
with even tame Lions is what happens is
it's called Instinct and all of a sudden
the tame lion goes oh wait that's a
horse now in the
wild I take those down might want to
take a at this well he doesn't though
right there's no horses in the wild
where TIG Bengal tigers but same thing
like if it's a deer or whatever that's
still a giant it's also a tiger doing
tiger [__] but if I'm uh I like when the
Tigers in lines that one there I like
when they fight back I'm I'm all for
it hell yeah use that towel and slap the
horse yeah we're not going to show this
okay well that's so what we're watching
is a guy rode in on a horse and the
tiger went I'm starving yeah well
they're both attacking it that's what
they do in the wild dude that's what
they do in the wild that's not good you
know what I do if I'm at that
circus well I mean that's just Bravo
it's just a lion and tiger doing tigers
do that's what they do they get
underneath and they pull them down and
they eat them it's yeah that my circus
was not like that I would pay look at
that thing way more money if it was a
circus yeah yeah cuz now cuz Peta gets
involved you can't do the elephants
can't do the Lions can't do tigers
definitely can't do CH horse is all
still going at them yeah of course you
got give a show Food Dude I like the guy
with the towel he keeps missing in the
horse oh my God just
just just and they're they're hamstring
the also is that the only precaution
there is is a towel yeah that's what I'm
saying the to also if I'm the if I'm the
dad at the thing I'm like hey kids let's
get get out of here cuz soon as they're
done with this horsey 100% o we're the
next vict that horse seems like he's
okay though shaking it off a lot of
blood though proba slit his throat okay
poor guy yeah he's going to bleed out
you got to get that horse to the vet but
they probably have to put that horse
down still a better show than what I got
yeah a better show I would pay so much
way you see that yeah yeah yeah but
tiger didn't believe me he's like Dad
you're lying like dude I'm telling you
lines Tigers elephants some had bears
bears too you had a you had a muzzled
bear
those animals had shitty lives so I I
support well that's why they freak out
that's why I like like remember when uh
what sick figed and Roy yeah remember
that line with that white tiger was like
you know what dude I'm sick of your [__]
man and I'm sick of you making me watch
you suck Roy off all the [__] time
I'm going to rip your throat out
remember that he was like you know what
not today well and do you know and do
you know he probably was like I don't
like your hair now here's the thing also
uh apparently he made a mistake and that
mistake was he fell down in front of him
and you can't do that with a tiger
apparently the tiger didn't eat him cuz
he said he tastes like
plastic well and he is made of plastic
and that's the only thing that saved his
life was the synthetic uh taste in his
mouth um I like when this stuff happens
what do you think was going to happen
were they lovers or something oh he was
deep in SE free yeah well okay oh dude
blowing those white bangal loads dud all
right all right yeah yeah he slime Roy
out uhhuh he slimed Roy out well bought
he bought don't say slime please he SL
CL he tiger slimed Roy out oh God he
clamped his powerful jaws around Roy's
neck dude clamped his powerful anus
around his C dragged dragged him 30 feet
off stage again I would pay hard cold
cash to see that no no no you would in
Vegas yeah oh dude that'd be a fantastic
show he grabbed him by the throat and
just walked off stage sign me up he died
right no no no no he he no he survived
that and came back he did yeah he came
back are you sure positive he didn't you
say a lot of things in no bring it up no
he didn't die
uhhuh no they're dead now from from
plastic in their face they didn't die
from the
tiger well hold on they died from Botox
I think yeah they may have died no that
tiger didn't kill him pancreatic cancer
yep if the tiger didn't get you cancer8
who was the other one who died though
was that the one who got bit uh sigfred
and Roy is their names yes but which one
got bit I need you to a little more
sensitive does it matter hey I Roy what
are you going to do with what are you
going to do with that info his Roy died
Roy horn there you go okay now what but
I would like you to be a little bit more
no no no now what we're in the weeds
here now I just just want you to be a
little bit more sensitive oh Roy got bit
crazy uh Monte Cory attacked Roy on
stage nearly killing him uh but was he
wasn't he paralyzed or something he got
messed up for sure yeah oh man yeah your
neck isn't made for Tiger bites your
neck is not made for for that kind of
pressure hey it's also what you get
though yeah well I that is the thing
right in other news you're going work
with
them bites through the neck slicing his
vertebrae and severing an artery that
cuts off the blood to the right side of
his brain drags oh my
God yeah he uh his neck's a little stiff
oh man he died after this though not
because of the attack but because of the
cancer
right how how's no one stepped in how
how are there not two young handsome
blos stepping in to get this Tigers
going they probably learned and also
exotic got them already I don't I don't
think you can do well they were when
they were young bring up them bring them
them when they were young they were they
were a couple cute peie twin a couple
Twinks in the fur Twinks in the fur
shizel Twinks in the fur dude they would
get off stage and [__] well I don't know
dude were they lovers yeah you pretty
sure they were together look hold up
dude you think these two started a
[__] tiger show sucking each other up
but here's the thing one had to be the
top and I feel like both seem like
strong bottoms no that guy on the right
the top strong guy on the right with all
the chains at the top he's Fantastic
look at his body dude o look at his
curls oh
that's nice look at that [__] that
Tiger's like okay yeah that's a lot of
work look at his nose I don't like his I
don't like his Thin Mustache in his perm
at all that Tiger's like how many stupid
pictures we got to take with YouTu they
were big cat experts dude you two queens
they wore open shirts and nobody knew
they were gay at first oh everyone knew
though but we just pretend yeah yeah
it's like Liberace yes
okay yeah Liberace was H bring up
Liberace and take a look at him I always
thought you dressed like you know way
wish but he he he wears too many he's a
gay Brennan CH oh he's on another level
could play the piano though
huh ah oh he couldn't get enough he
couldn't get enough decoration you
[__] Christmas tree what's crazy is
back then they had like stories that he
was married it was just a fake marriage
cuz they didn't want the public to find
out but also dude dude everyone knew he
was a lady and you know um you could use
him as a lighthouse you could use him to
keep shs you could start a fire yeah you
could use him start a fire yeah you know
what with all that glasses and hairspray
and yeah he he is he's solar powerered
he he could absolutely warm a small V
did you ever see Matt Damon play his
boyfriend I did not and then Michael
Douglas is I didn't I heard it was great
oh behind the calabra or whatever the
[__] it's called be the calabra
calabra calabra calabra be on the
calabra yes the cand oh it's fantastic
oh well dude I'll watch it once a year I
don't know if that makes me gay but I
can't do you watch it I watch that and
True Blood call me gay no once a year
True Blood and behind the c calabra the
truth is you're um Matt Damon that in
his chin is fantastic you're actually
gayer than I am but and and and you
should be appla you know what's weird
you know how you jack off the Special
Forces guys and there's so many of them
and black guys black AET so many of
those anybody muscular mine's this
mine's this and Jared Leto that's it
only two yeah well you like you like you
like decoration you like flamboyant I
mean you like a man with style if you're
going go gay you got to go all you also
like a gender bender you you you
appreciate a gender bender you like a a
sort of an
androgynous decorated oh yeah I mean a
man you you can smell his perfume not
even colone but perfume before he gets
into the room I yeah I like a man smells
like wood and Moss like death that's I
don't like that he's a beautiful young
man he really is he's 50 dude he's older
than 50 great body 52 now I think that's
incredible just Crush life big UFC
fan loves the UFC does he have you met
him never I wish I did I've seen him at
did the was a party next to him or at
the UFC next to well Rogan said he's
just a great guy he couldn't believe how
normal he was
those piercing blue eyes probably a
distraction if you're
fighting God damn pink hair with a Gucci
fit dog I mean you love him yeah he's my
favor he knows the [__] B let's take a
little break I'm headed Niagara Falls
November 4th and 5th I'm at The Comedy
Store tomorrow night with some monsters
where you going to be buddy I'll be at
the shamberg inro Buddy uh October 2728
then I'm at Raleigh North Carolina good
nights November 9 10 and 11 got that
going for me all right were you watching
the NFL dude you watching college
watching the NFL and uh if you're
watching the NFL you need to make some
bank cuz the NFL is better than ever and
draftking Sportsbook is hooking new
customers up with an offer that's even
stronger than this NFL season bet five
bucks on any game this week score $200
and instantly in bonus bets and
DraftKings isn't stop in there all
customers can take advantage of a
sweeter offer every game day this
October
uh bet on the Dolphins the Jags are good
this year bet on the 49ers and the 49ers
ners probably the best team in the
league I think not the Cowboys not the
Cowboys get in on the game day greatness
download the draftking Sportsbook app
right now use the code fighter new
customers can score $200 instantly in
bonus bets when you bet five on the NFL
that's code fighter only on DraftKings
sports book an official sports betting
partner the NFL gambling problem called
gambling or is www1 1800 gambler. net in
New York call 8778 hope Andy or text
heny 467 369 in Connecticut help us
available for problem gambling call
8887895118
expire 7 days after issuance eligibility
and deposit restrictions apply
DraftKings BR code fighter he's a star I
don't what am I going to say in 30
Seconds to Mars he can sing too he can
sing
yeah he can sing um yeah but I went to a
circus yeah went to a circus you went to
the circus went to the circus and tiger
had a game yesterday he did balling well
I feel like that you showed me what he
did that kid is a uh I mean is he going
to the majors I told you you want a
meeting we're we're starting now 10 mil
get in the get get your get your foot in
the door manage him I don't I got to
give you 10 mil just to talk to him what
you got to wet our beat dude a lot of
competition listen listen I I nobody's
going to care about this kid more than
me all right let me be the man that
builds the road to the major leagues you
don't know baseball though I don't the
problem I have watched it I have watched
but I have watched you sound like his
coach right
now I said did you play this nah never
does he he
clearly is that what he said yeah nah
never man I watch a lot of it I went
what wow he you know goes at this level
I go wait hold on you never played n n
no h you been here six
seasons oh dude where I'm at D do you
know anything about sports went where do
I start yeah how far you want to go go
back you got to get him to a real
program I'll take it from here yeah get
him in a real program oh yeah yeah
you're coaching him right now a little
bit right oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah and
it's just repetition now day now um he
does stand out doesn't he yes and he's
hand eye coordination strength all of
that he's a better way better athlete
than I was at his AG is that right not
even close really not of your don't say
well don't K yourself your wife's family
your wife's brother is an athlete that
kid's an athlete yeah he played played
baseball yeah High Level Baseball yeah
he was throwing when we were playing
dodgeball he thr was like chill he was
thr a b dodge ball so I was like that's
a [__] UFO that looks like a like
literally it would whistle past us it
was actually changing like changing it
was like when Billy Madison was playing
with the kids like oh my God was like
whoa like hey you can't play uhuh yeah
you can throw I couldn't believe that
yeah then yeah Joanna's athletic too you
played volleyball with her I did play
volleyball with her she's got some
strength for a Mexican for
she's she's Italian Mexican too isn't
she y yeah she's all curved up not that
I noticed I would never notice that I
was walking behind her at one point I
remember I go Joanna seriously she goes
what I go I mean it's a little
ridiculous I remember I remember what
are we doing you know what I mean but
even even my father-in-law yesterday you
know cuz you my mother-in-law's you know
she's a dime by the way she had these
jeans on he goes she's the same thing he
goes he goes he calls her my mom he goes
your mom's ass your mom can we look at
your mom's ass like did you sign up for
this it's true she's when you say
grandmother you think grandmother she's
my age and well well just looks so much
better than I do at my age just
preserved oh if we go to dinner
everyone's like you know it's it's
stupid they'll both shut the room down
in in the movie in apple in the soap
opera movie you know the twist is that
the baby is actually hers and yours yes
yes
yeah you know what I mean yeah but Mom
by movie you mean you mean well Joe's
like Joe's like how dare you and you're
like but babe she looks just like you
and it was dark and I was drunk you know
yep yep you know what I'm saying you do
that so that would be weird I'm eating
big J Shob in Sacramento on Friday
picking up my truck daddy how scared are
you going to be on my truck I'm it's not
for you is it no what what are just so I
can be be more opposite of what just so
I can be annoyed what horsepower are you
getting it up to we should be 1100 is
that good is that a lot and you're going
to drive that bad the the [__] crazy
thing is that's your everyday driver
I'll drive it every day every day I
can't handle it you just can't get
enough no but you can't get enough meat
under the hood you can't there's too
much potential you just can't it's like
staring at a painting going nah we're
not done yet my buddy Dave used to date
girls that were so plastic and I said to
him one day I said dude do her tits have
to be that fake and he goes I like tits
to look too fake I want them to look I
don't want them to be fake I want them
to look fake where people go that's not
that's a disaster the time with cars
you're saying yes yeah I just like crazy
[__] if the potential's out there I
can't stop thinking about it I just like
wild [__] in cars yeah if I know you can
toss this supercharger on this pulley on
why not dude it's so fun and then the
car Community is nuts they're so dope so
supportive like the hatam this kib Tech
they're one of the biggest brands in the
world I didn't know this they're right
his office is right up here they're
right so I was like I'm going to stop by
he's like come by private shop I just
come by hang out with them talk shop kby
tech and and what what do they do do
they soup cars up is that the right word
they do suspension they do suspension
just suspension uh no they can do it all
but
that's sence is that a science oh my God
cuz they do like Baja like racing like
the Baja racing right it it's not you're
talking about and here's the thing
they're the best in the world and
they're right up here and it's a dude
who's from Cali americanmade does a he
take literally takes the
parts custom makes it himself for the
cars it's nuts all Amic why doesn't why
don't the uh why don't you just pour
magic mine into the fuel tank oh I might
try that in your electric car
guys if you're into souping up your car
that's one thing soup up your body if
you want to soup your body up you want
to soup your body up just take this tiny
shot of magic mine not only is it
delicious but it soups you up now I
don't have to go down to a shop in
Sacramento but when I drink this I feel
like I'm running on 1,00 horsepower you
get turbocharged it's like put fuel in I
need more gas I don't need more gas do I
no it's got its own gas thanks magic M
for souping my body up souping me you
soup your body up I soup my cars up it's
the One-Stop shop look guys you find
American it's American made you
fine-tune your car fine-tune your body
with magic mind now here's the problem
be when you soup up these Char these
cars they need to be they need to run on
E85 fuel oh God so Daddy had to download
an
app cuz there only you don't know where
the E85 ah but there's a lot around here
here's where it gets tricky when you're
driving from Sacramento to LA and you
know that TRX is going to get about five
miles a gallon yeah yeah I'm going to
have to figure out stops along the way
to get E85 oh boy cuz it won't accept
any other
gasoline so what is E85 that Flex field
vehicle offer lot of
corn yeah it's corn it's ethanol
yep it's ethanol yeah but here's here's
the plus a85 so so so gas right now is
like $7 thanks Biden that that stays
around three oh it does never it doesn't
cuz it's not oil so it doesn't go up and
down like Biden screws us be honest with
you right now be honest with you yeah
please do um you're going to have a hard
time finding oh no e E85 so easy I don't
know if it is BB cuz it's not for you I
haven't seen that though I know but
you're a
[__] right so you wouldn't even know if
you wouldn't you wouldn't even know if
you was there that is an unfair you
cannot call me a fuel no dude no I'm not
a cuck because I don't know where you no
if you'd notice if it said like 91 93
gas giant black [__] like oh there it is
but because says E85 like I don't see
them no that's not I think you're being
very unfair now I have an app there's so
many once you once you're become to it
there's so yeah there's so many it's not
going to be a problem there's one a
block from my house check there's one a
block from the studio check so that so
that way you so you only make two you
only have to make two stops from here to
the to the studio good it's just what
you got to do dude right have you done a
have you done a little Su something on
what kind of gas mileage you're going to
get it's not more than 9 miles per
gallon yeah uh well right now like city
is probably to like not joking probably
City's around nine and then highways
probably 12 yeah adding adding the
horsepower yeah I I would assume I get
around 10 or nine 10 or n yeah so that
and that's you know you sp 100 Grand on
fuel yeah but you know the Direction all
you cucks going like electric China all
that I'm going this way cuz I'm American
rightz I'm American if you want to if
you want to bend the knee to China Drive
your electric if you want to ruin the
environment drive your electric I feel
like you're being if you don't like the
sound of horsepower and gas engines
drive your cuck electric mobile to China
please it's not fair to turn me into
commun you're communist cuck I look I go
the opposite just because I drive an
electric car doesn't mean I'm in the
corner masturbating while my my my lady
takes on other men that's just not a
fair comparison really I mean I am
probably I I just assumed it was a thing
I assumed if you drive Tesla I can inv
like your wife well no I just thought
dimm the rules no no yeah I thought dimm
the rules like when I see you driving a
Tesla does not mean my wife is is fair
game who told you that I thought when
you signed the contract it says that you
can you you can drive in the high Lane
but you're not allowed to no that's not
the high Lane I'm talking about this is
new to me no dude it's where I draw the
line plus need to explain this better to
me cuz I whenever I see people in the
HOV lane with their electric cars and
there's only one person I'm like I'll
Just Fall them home and [__] his wife no
no no dude I don't think that's what it
means bro Oh weird dude yeah look it
just we're just trying to you know not
stop at the gas station so often and
keep the environment the air clean wow I
I need look more into it yeah yeah yeah
cuz I just thought no no and I just feel
cuz they do give me a weird look where
I'm like suck me no yeah no no no it's
like a full does does his wife look at
you when you drive by she was like this
oh yeah
I'm she was and is your car going to be
louder now oh boy impossibly Lou it's to
be my neighbors are going to hate me
rock and
roll
poll wow yeah so what do you think when
you see
a man Roll by in a just do my favor
honest if you if you see a dude pull up
in a a Tesla three three all white all
white white on white could be more cish
white
onela red Prius which I used to
whichever pick your poison pick your
pick your soft poison or you see someone
pull up in like a I don't know a demon
[__] Challenger I mean I don't want
to say the word but if I see the
Challenger I'm going to think this guy
yeah oh damn oh like
rules rules di the rules damn but the
guy in the Tesla could too he'd just be
a little more sensitive about it I don't
want to be that
guy I thought it was a first choices is
demon Raptor of me this guy [__] don't
say demon Raptor cuz those two different
brands and that makes him want to hit
you okay but it doesn't mean cuz they're
two separate [__] Brands that's like
saying I'm with Red Sox I apologize I
apologize I didn't know that you're the
one who said demon you have a raptor
though right no okay I don't know
they're the enemy oh a Dodge Demon TRX
oh a TRS with a Hellcat engine a demon
is a challenger and the Demon's the it's
basically my engine but with a bigger
blower on it okay blower means
supercharger okay a
blower either way that gets you go that
guy's an alpha that guy's over the top
or you know you're gonna have some fun
the guy in t like okay he's not he's not
husband material but he's definitely
[__] boy material I didn't say that okay
but that's what you would assume I mean
yeah yeah he's got a he's got he's got
shoulders on him he's got a forward tilt
to him did some sport he's got big traps
for sure he might not be able to touch
his neck they're so bad big traps big
dick and he'll protect you sure yeah not
not necessarily big and then when we
look over in the Tesla we're assuming
she say whoa here she comes Watch Out
Boy sh chew you up and like headed to
Marshalls right why would I go to
Marshall cuz it's lame as [__] right
Marshall is so I used to go as a kid my
mom take me all the time I enjoy it I I
said Marshall's man it's got kicked
though my
Tesla save it save it t in and out quiet
did you pop for that auto drive with
yours what's that yeah has auto drive oh
kind of you and I drove in that thing it
was so dangerous dangerous we Brian's
like check oh my god well I knew when
when when Lex Freedman who designed it
for Elon Musk was on Rogan ran goes well
if it if it fails he goes not if when it
fails and I was like well if you're
saying that but what's scary I I don't
know how I feel about it because in San
Francisco they're using those cars that
drive themselves like Ubers you can just
jump into it's come to LA and then once
it hits La then everyone copies us as
usual right but you know like I think
it's like 93% of car crashes are human a
so think about it if it's controlled by
a robot and they get it done in time
where it's that safe you can save 93% of
car crashes that crazy yeah that's
always good now Daddy's still going to
have to rip right yeah you CU America
it's you're going to be the only one I'm
going to rip and all of us are going to
be like this oh god oh the Judgment if
you can get jump in a a safe yeah it'd
be like a special for dude who who who
just kind of in a in middle of a battle
stumbles into a woman's yoga slm
Meditation Retreat be frown upon you
know what I mean candles flowers there's
incense yeah there's and he just and
they're all like and he's like sorry
sorry and he just and and all the girls
immediately start ovulating even though
they find him even though they find him
totally vulgar well you're rock hard
right now huh yeah I am yeah yeah I am
cuz I'm one of the girls yeah I know cuz
I'm literally in a wig and you're like
Brian I'm like I can explain we remember
in Sopranos do you remember when when
the guy was uh blowing you find out that
the guy's gay yeah and he's dancing he's
got a hat on and he's in the club yeah
with a guy and the two guys come in to
collect and they see him and he's like
no I can explain I can explain what
about it they kill him hell yeah dude
bad it's bad yeah it's not good there
was a gay twist in sanos dude are you
excited for Dylan danis Logan Paul this
Saturday I am excited about that you're
going to miss it though
huh be at a wedding be at a wedding
brenon where's the wedding at
Florida what I like to do is fly across
the country who wedding it's family
which family cousin nope I know nope
nope NOP Noe Noe no I know not a cousin
alive that I'd fight a FL I understand
that I understand that and they you know
what and they get it that's why we're
family they get it was your wedding
Florida you know I can't come why cuz I
can't no no it's too far it's too far
yeah it's too far so you leave on Friday
it's just too far but I kind of have to
go um I leave on Saturday morning brenon
I'm going to leave
and I'm going to get there I'm going to
just get there and it's fun though it'll
be fun I it's going to be a terrible
time I like them I like them people man
what a nightmare I'd be like hey you
know I travel for a living it's you know
I I I I it's so painful for me you live
on a people don't realize how what it's
like to sit on a plane like the way we
do I love being home no I've cut back
dude I I can't but you love being home I
can't I love it I love it too I don't
want to go anywhere else I just want to
be at home I can't do it I do not want
to be anywhere else
um so you miss the Dylan danis Logan
because it starts at I think the walk
here
around 12 I I think in boxing Dylan's
got his hands full am I am I wrong about
that no you and everybody else okay
think so he's a Logan looks as good as
you can look he's jacked
jacked um but so the main card starts
here too that's what I'm saying but the
the actual gu so that means they
probably will walk here around 3 who is
the better athlete would you say uh
Logan for sure better
athlete but a better athlete doesn't
always win no no but but how much boxing
has dlan Dennis done how much have
either of them done well yeah he hasn't
competed two years Logan hasn't boxed um
he's never won a fight brother Logan's
never won a fight
yeah he lost to KSI I think he had a
draw with another YouTuber they lost to
Floyd that's why you were saying he
doesn't want any part of um Mike Perry
no no nobody does right no DL
sit but Dylan is a Dylan's a fighter man
and Dylan has a lot of experience but he
hasn't fought since
2019 it's good well this is a good F
coming off knee surgery it's an
interesting fight because you know
they're not even the main event KSI uh
Tommy Fury is the main event nobody he's
talking about it though yeah what do you
think of that Tommy should dominate
yes um but I'm more interested in Dylan
and Logan and I I think Dylan's going to
go in there I I think he's goingon to do
some off-the-wall [__] I think he's
going to try and choke him unconscious
what do you mean in a boxing he's a wild
boy yeah that's what I think it's gonna
happen really yep I think they have to
separate them and they're the fights
going to be in no contest that's what I
think because Dylan doesn't want to
stand toe to- toe I think yeah I think
he's going to go in he's not going to
have success early on the feet and be
like [__] it choke him out
he's a lot smaller than Logan or no not
that much smaller okay Logan's
definitely a lot more muscular and
taller he has a inch and a half reach
Advantage but this level doesn't matter
does
it can we see Dylan danis like hitting
mits or anything I haven't seen him he's
had MMA fights but it's mostly had two
wrestling yeah two submissions in kind
of train with uh Alex paa a little bit
sparring apparently it was good rounds
that's what they say that's what Alex
said I mean Dylan Dennis has got to be a
dog either way a what a dog he's he's
he's definitely an
underdog so we can't really well I'll
show a little bit of this yeah but
that's I don't I don't know what no we
don't want to see him grappling I know I
know hold on uh I think uh Logan is a
minus 350 favorite I think it's fair mhm
I don't know I just I just don't know
right that's my thing we trying to break
down the shop sh I listen guys usually
I'll give you some insight here I don't
know what to tell you
but all your hands are down there
brother sparring footage is like that
good keep your hands down it's whatever
I don't
know but they're kicking here so yeah
it's not the same doesn't look like he's
been doing a lot of boxing training sir
we can't base off social media hold on
this is a 16-year-old girl calling you
hold on oh no no oh I'm sorry he's
watching Tik Tok and then judging the
guys fighting oh there you
go all right well there you go brenon
choking out he's going to do some wild
[__] I'm telling you man he's going to
get frustrated and pull that and they
have to separate into no contest and
fans going be so upset he's going to get
sued
again I'm sure that's in the contract if
he does a submission just same way Nate
Diaz had really dyl Dan is a wild boy
man Wild Boy submission would be so
strange what are you doing we'd be
talking about it though that's all he
wants yeah
I'm excited for it I'm excited I'm
excited Tommy Fury I don't even know how
to pay for it how do you get done Zone
Chen theone done Zone's an app I have it
yeah I I subscrib I want to watch on my
TV not my phone you can get it just
download the app really yeah really easy
how much is the
pay-per-view there's no way they're
charging 100 bucks are they that's
rude oh not bad $24.99 that is a solid
deal Y for the subscription
yeah I'm going to watch it um currently
this is the sole method to access the
pay-per-view section of KSI that means
that's the only way that's so you have
to subscription can I cancel it after or
am I forced to watch their other trash
content it's a $55 $54.99 solid deal
take my money I want to do a fight
campanion you me Bradley Martin and
tripley how that would have been great
that would been fun that would have been
love to do
that well I'm looking forward to it what
is your so so you'll be flying what's
your call what's your call Tommy Fury
Tommy Fury over KSI uh I don't know I
don't know but he should win Y and then
danis uh if if danis does do something
Wild
yeah if danis does do something just
crazy wild I would assume
Logan
interesting I think Logan suing him
takes away from the Logan is suing him
his his fiance is she is
yes okay and then on on Jake Paul's
podcast they talking about how they
garnered his wages and all the [__] for
the rest of his life it's like I don't
like that yeah that's not
cool the KSI Tommy Fury face off was
atrocious why Yeah just they should do
it see it makes you kind of the Logan
Paul Dylan Dennis one was good that's
what they're good at that that Nano U
Fury Fury uh trailer great just great
high level production yes yeah it's
about time smart and very good uh does
of that mag too that's what they need
yeah now now our boy and Gano I think is
working with Teddy Atlas and Tyson or is
that just one-offs no he's working with
them but his coach Nick sick is the
coach who's you know he's one of the
best we have in the business by far and
what do you
think same thing as always I think tyon
or Francis has a puncher's chance and he
has to get done early he needs to just
throw caution the went and bull rush him
yeah he has two rounds to get it done
after that it's going to be a nightmare
yeah cuz Fury will just figure him out
pick him apart yeah oh this is what
you're going to do okay I'll just stand
over here but he he just needs to go
balls to the wall and hopefully catch
him y both are going to make a fortune
yeah they'll make a lot of money yeah
it's a win-win for both of them if Tyson
loses that'd be awful for him yes
yeah yeah Brian what do you think about
uh Fury already booking the usk fight I
think I'm really excited about that
fight I mean he's so much bigger than
usk and no we don't want you break down
the fight what do you think of him
agreeing to fight usyk which is toughest
fight weeks after Francis fight I think
um you know what I'm saying yeah I think
I think it makes sense and here's why I
think he's going to be very finely tuned
so he has to do one fight Camp keep that
going and then you know provid doesn't
get hurt or anything and then it's like
let me let me let me make fast work of
Gana he's got to know that he's going to
be able to figure him out that's just
him assuming it's easy work but it's
going to be a sparring match for him in
his mind
and I think he's probably right the
smart money would say that and then he
goes all right good so I just get no R
ring rust and I go right into usk who is
smaller but a [__] such a
technical boxer just such an the best
100% now usyk is 220 Tyson is 600 lb so
and way taller so you know it'll be
interesting but if anybody I just can't
believe usyk did what he did to
um Anthony Joshua who is 250 he did to
him twice yeah man it's like wow and I
was watching a breakdown of that fight
too like usyk sets traps he does all
kinds of stuff that just High Lev [__]
Tech he's as good as we have right he's
36 too you got to remember he's been
fighting for a long time and those
Russians ukrainians whatever they from
Ukraine yeah they break that [__] down
it's like
every he's such a Savage such a a Savage
man such a Savage I just don't get why
if you're Fury why not do it in February
do you have to do it a few weeks after
you know how disrespectful that
is yeah it's smart though is it yeah I
don't know if it's smart cuz what
headbutt get hurt headbutt happens a cut
happens can you postpone
it it's just not smart there's no upside
to doing it right after there is though
just to because you're these are
professionals yeah but you don't to
another Camp right but but what you do
have to do is you're focus on MMA figh
in Francis then got to refocus on a
straight up skilled boxer who's 6 to 220
lbs yeah but isn't it isn't it a fact
that he's been boxing for so long that
it's just training as as business as
usual though no there's going to have to
be a crazy game plan against usk yeah
he's never fought somebody like us
amazing man usyk's a
[__]
[__] but isn't there like I just
feel like um he's just going to box the
way he boxes isn't he or does he have to
game you have to have game [__] yeah you
got a game plan at this level you can't
just go in there and hope for the best
watch tape and watch what do [__] yes
hell yes he's probably doing that now
he's also a Southpole oh Jesus usyk's
Southpaw [__] Francis is not so you're
going traditional conventional F
Orthodox dance to a southpaw who's the
best technical boxer you've ever faced
in a matter of weeks no he's fought
South Paws before same trainer as um
lomachenko right same camp same uh I
don't know I think so pretty
sure um wow
[__] how how long after the inano fight
is he fighting it's supposed to be
December or January they're I think
December is like the what they're
targeting but it might be January they
announced December soone leak December
but I and I I to your point I think
they're kind of like all right if the if
the France fight didn't go as easy as we
think let's do this in J yeah if he
smokes in a round or two or three or
four and he doesn't get hurt let's do it
in December yeah if he doesn't get hurt
how much time does he take off when's he
back in the gym but he takes a week off
yeah he's a Savage kudos to him
yeah 100% apparently from that that TV
show he he's a bit of a spend
Thrift oh really the Gypsy not good with
his
money like but he's but it's not that
he's good with mad with money he's a
little bipolar so he'll be like I want
to buy a castle and I want to buy a
house Pony and I want a baby tiger and a
spacecraft and she's and his wife is
like no no and no well that's why his
wife around his team around but he's
getting lump sums of like 40 50 60
million so yeah dude yeah but we all
know that goes you can spend it we all
know that there are plenty of people
that just all of a sudden are broke like
what look at Nicholas Cage and we got a
lot of shitty movies to pay for yeah so
what do you got Jen
all right well I think Canelo made like
50 mil for the charer fight which is
crazy yeah 50 50 mil yeah that's not
surprising good for good for Char too
these boys are making money it's
beautiful uh so I just saw this pop up
recently uh Rogan's deal with Spotify is
going to end in like 11 months so who
knows what's going to happen but yeah I
have it's close what do you think he
does I think they back the brink trucks
up I think he resigns cuz they've done
they they signed Dak sheeper they signed
caller daddy signed a few others none of
them has added value or the viewership
they didn't cross over like Rogan did so
I think spotif me like all right let's
cut them their deals are up because they
signed all the same time we're going to
keep Rogan but I assume they have to pay
him more money well I I think a couple
things are GNA happen one is I think
this is all speculation I haven't talked
to Joe but one is Joe will Spotify stood
by him during the co thing they stood by
him they also stood by him during the
the yeah that was the biggest one thing
whatever the N word thing was a big one
yeah and they stood by him but even with
the co thing remember a lot of like Neil
Young Jonny Mitchell a lot of people
were like I'm take my music off until
you get him yeah they're all cucks like
okay there was there was pressure and
they kiss my ass Young's like I'm taking
my catalog Spotify went but so Rogan is
very loyal that way and my guess is he
he will never forget that number one
number two um I think what's if I was
Joe and I was his and I'm not but if I
was his people I would say now let's
take a look at how much your stock has
grown since he came on yeah yeah so I
always said he got underpaid we'll take
a piece of the company yep we'll take a
we you know give us this and then you
know what's it worth to you that's all
just let's do some math math is going to
tell us that he's probably going to get
a crazy deal correct but let me ask you
this let's say Spotify for whatever
reason um I have no clue they're going
to but let's say they don't offer them
so take Spotify off the oh no then what
do you do then you go back to making a
fortune on YouTube and no no that's not
an option YouTube's not an option oh
well then then what you do is you start
your own payall there's the move you
start your own like sort of company
where you know you and people will come
that's what Lis Gomez did they have
their own gank Fest behind their own
it's not L Gomez is a good business yeah
it's not patreon it's their own thing
they did it way before Pat start they
did a long time ago I know wish we
thought of it yeah we didn't but if if
I'm Rogan i' do that
yeah man because YouTube's going to be
more censored because the ele remember
the election's coming up in 2024 so the
censorships can get much worse so Rogan
can't live on there talk it's going get
much worse yeah I know for a fact I talk
to people I'm also getting a lot of
stuff on my feed that is pushing uh a
very interesting leftwing agenda that's
cuz you look at that stuff cuz I don't
get so weird that it's popping up all of
a sudden see I don't get that stuff
what's going on well they why why are
they [__] with my algorithm because
they can compromise you yeah it's the
stuff you're looking at it only
recommends stuff that they think you're
interested in it doesn't send me that
stuff right well you drive a TRX yeah it
sent me something to storm the capital I
was like what I'm not into this when is
it is there free coffee I'm sorry yeah
but yeah if I'm Rogan I I would uh I
would start my own thing I wouldn't go
on YouTube or any of that I'd start my
own
thing
that's if Spotify doesn't back up the
Brinks truck which I think they
will but they only other option start
your own thing y I think that's the only
that is the only option yeah it seems
that it's not I don't think YouTube's
not or or you know who else is a player
in this Rumble rumble's a great player
in this Rumble is if they have the money
I don't know if they have that much
Capital it's not it's not a question of
money for rumble it's a question of
bandwidth so it's a question of I think
um can you can do you have the
infrastructure to handle that kind of TR
they do cuz they have Russell Brand and
stuff like that it'd be money would be
you have to do do you have the capital
where you can pay somebody like Rogan to
be on your platform I think that's where
there would be a lot of people who who
institutional money that would say we'll
we'll sign up there are people in and
you the yeah Rumble is uh rumble's
really impressed me with how where they
they brass balls and standing with
Russell BR well they impressed me CU
they don't do anything yeah that that's
impressive they're not sens they're not
into sens ship or demonetizing people
yeah just off
of news articles what else you got this
is a cool little clip of uh Utah
football players everyone that with a
scholarship got a truck a brand new
truck W are like
damn wait how did this
work I mean the trucks are branded with
the so I think they get 83 scholarship
athletes that's 83 Ram
1500s so it's it costs around $5 million
I think for the lease but they're least
so I think they only have them for a
certain amount of time there's not
screen right here there a full iPad
screen yeah they all got trucks who gave
it to them Dodge dealer and Utah I bet
for the N it's a great looking yeah but
they have to have that for the win thing
on it with that yeah
well they're going to get theirs but I
mean they that's impressive yeah
a free Dodge Ram 1500 I'd be
stoked I'd be like this um do you guys
have an electric car I can trade this
[Laughter]
for oh what kind of gas does this
take what's this uh Georgie this
remember back when we saw the video of
Jamal Murray and Alexander vulcanos
besties uh I didn't know this but the
whole entire team had to do jisu
training that day and who learn
Jiu-Jitsu can beat anybody in one month
Colorado I would assume oh that's at
East oh that's at uh yeah that's atach
NBA players they can beat anybody in
Jiu-Jitsu in a month cuz they have long
legs right Brennon and long arms right
no I don't think I'm just kid although
it would go a long way with these giant
dudes I would imagine it's not if they
only did it for one day no that's true
look yourself up go hey Elliot just
teach them arm barss and stuff though
right they're doing like the train
they're doing like shrimping and
falling oh yeah Marshall's got a hell of
a school oh yeah the
best I mean they're going out right
there where's J I want to see jokic he
makes too much money joic is like I'm
not Going's go let's go let's go who is
that there we go
thumbs touching the armpit everyone see
it all right go 1 2 3 all right everyone
take them down go
ahead well that's cool that's pretty
cool long thin men uh SN yeah have this
one all right wait what is this this one
makes me gag even talking about I can't
even watch it well you're going to have
to I just read the headline why are they
do Kevin Gates rapper uh Infamous
prisoner whatever we want to refer to
him as went ahead and uh kicked off his
only the genitals tour and invited a
woman on stage and asked her pretty much
can I do whatever I want to you and she
said yes and this is what he proceeded
to
do is her boyfriend in the crowd like
yeah give him G I've seen that guy at
air Bubba give it up for Kevin seen that
guy a yeah I know give it up for Kevin
why would he do this he's like what are
we what are you doing babe no I can't do
it what's his name Kevin
Gates turn it off J no it's it's really
runchy but why is he doing that and I
thought he was way more spiritual I've
heard he's very spiritual yeah so what's
he doing I hey he's not spiritual right
you bought that you [__] what's he
you're a rapper face that dude right I
know but like he talks about Bible verse
yeah all this stuff so Stone Cold Steve
Austin but but I've seen him he's got
little dogs I've seen him yeah sure dude
yeah he's a
sweetie why would you do that leave him
in a room around your girl why would you
do that bro take your girl to that
concert let me know how swee is so low
class man what are you doing that's not
right SAS give me your take on that is
there any artist you allowed to spin
your face absolutely not there there is
no way anyone's Hawking anything in my
mouth [__] I'd go to 3 seconds of
mar the only person the only person I
would let do that is Jared let but
that's it maybe 3 seconds to
B yeah there are girls I would probably
let spit in my mouth I don't care maybe
not a lugie not a lug I can't I'll throw
up on stage but like spit in my face
yeah I mean if you're making like a
Hillary conc doesn't matter what you're
making that's a difference that's like
when people are like we make out why
can't we use the same toothbrush that's
gross hakal Lugi in my mouth no no but
just like that had viscosity no that's
nasty viscosity is not I go there I'd
let Rihanna spit in my face yeah yeah of
course probably not like what the cuz it
I don't think so it doesn't turn me on
I'm like oh okay oh my God I let Katy
Perry do it front row yeah but brenon
you let freaking Tai TOA spit a lugie
into the shoe and you Dr
drr he drank it though like you Dr spit
yeah oh man what are you talking about
now a giant it fat lugie it was godamn
and I did throw up [__] how did you I'm
not Australian dude I can't I'd let
Carri Perry spit my face Katy Perry and
Carrie Perry both
yeah dude I gotta talk to this guy when
I see
him Kevin Gates isn't a very rapper
name what's this all right I got one
more for you you know I'm a big WWE gal
but Dwayne The Rock Johnson and Oprah
got some backlash of a while ago they
came out you know trying to put this
fund together to donate money to people
in Hawaii because of the fires but they
got a lot of [__] for it and you know
the working man is like here we are
watching these two asking us for money
and we're living paycheck to paycheck
but the thing I think people forget is
that these two donated 5 million each
too and and did they say that in the
video I do not like if the rock was say
that if the rock was like Hey everybody
I just donated $5 million to the Maui
Foundation whatever you know whatever
you can give more than good but they
were just like hey everybody Maui's on
fire give us your money I also have to
say that I the two richest people this
is where government comes in and tax
dollars come in and emergency funds come
in Ukraine took all that yeah we don't
need uh we don't need to uh but I'm
going to tell you a couple things on
foreign aid for a second that people
forget oh hell yeah dude but they do so
when you say [__] yeah when we say we
yes we gave $70 billion to Ukraine it's
not really it's not that much not what
we did yeah so you know how that works
it's kind of interesting no please
explain what 1% of the US budget goes to
foreign aid and when you hear 40 billion
70 billion to Ukraine what it really
means is that they're sending weapons
food and things like that right guess
what though it's kind of sneaky the
reason you don't hear Congress and a lot
of people freaking out about it who know
is this well okay 70 $40 billion right
to Ukraine do you know who makes those
weapons American comp companies do you
know who makes that food all the
clothing and everything else all the
supplies American companies it's kind of
a sneaky way of putting the money back
into the US economy so what they do is
it's a government subsidy so the
government kind of goes let's let's you
know here a couple companies 10
companies 15 companies here's a contract
make this make this make this so they
actually get paid new some that's why no
this is a fact so that's why you see
congressmen who are not against they
don't allude to it well no but
congressmen know that their constituents
are very happy because the aid actually
is a way of stimulating the US economy
byting the US economy to make all those
war war is good for business yeah
unfortunately I actually didn't know
that though because you hear a lot of
people say it's a blank check and that's
what that's political re rhetoric
actually it's way more layered than that
but I was surprised by that and I was
always wondering because it's like it's
secretly everybody in Congress is like
uh hey [__] it's actually kind of good
for the it's a way of stimulating it's a
of getting the government to give money
to people so yeah I think the Rock and
Oprah a little just tonee to this the
two richest people I felt that way when
I saw it I was like I didn't see it nor
would I click on it but uh you're
talking about two of the richest yeah
and that's what he said he like realizes
he was a little toned after the
situation he's like apologizing well he
should have just been like yo I donated
5 million just to start if you guys
match it who however many it takes I'll
donate another 5 million and to your
point I'll do jaman
to your point if we can spend $70
billion on Ukraine we we have the money
for Hawaii and so that's what it is it's
like no no no I'm not giving money no no
matter give tax dollars no matter what
money however you figure we're getting
the 70 billion to Ukraine you know that
same money could go to protecting the
borders oh well that's how about the
fact that Biden's building a wall oh how
about he blames the Republicans now he's
building a wall now like I've always
said we needed a wall it's like huh
what yeah it's interesting what else you
got Jen all right last one MMA related
so Derrick Lewis is going to replace
your boy Curtis blades to headline sa
Paulo and he's going to have you seen
the sa fight super athlete Jiu-Jitsu
specialist submits everybody Under the
Sun was supposed to fight Curtis blades
which would have been a much more
interesting matchup now you got Derrick
Lewis Derrick Lewis it it's a tough call
it's tough to call here because digl hit
so [__] hard but if he's on his back
he's like a turtle and he can get ankle
locked knee barred arm if Alo will go
straight to mount and just do work he's
a Savage just sick
jiujitsu ridiculous ridiculous and like
real athlete for a heavyweight super
athlete go outo so Brian knows who we're
talking about J derck
Lewis we're all familiar with Derek the
Lewis oh yeah he's a [__] beast wow
you just saw a picture of a black guy
and said he's Beast seen Jesus Christ
seen you know nothing about went mad
that guy's no no I've seen him I've seen
him fight he's a
monster I mean he took Rosen streo right
down yeah
monster God tough fight for derck Lewis
he's like a he's like a bigger jakare
huh like a bigger crocodile he's not
that good no
no 32 63 231 can you bring them up cuz I
got I love how how these Brazilians age
it's my favorite bring up a picture of
them yeah look at take a look at his
face
there looks a little older than 32 he
looks about every bit of 32 there he
looks young I don't know but he does
look older when you see him in person
they like that right there I mean that's
a that's a that's a worn face that's a
32-year-old he's punched in the face he
has bad skin too that's the other thing
yeah a lot of GES though a lot of jitsu
you can have bad skin
yeah it's an interesting fight though
two clashing Styles our boy uh the best
body in the history of the APO yeah he's
got staff infection yeah he had surgery
like two weeks ago for staff that it was
that bad bad yeah they have to go and
carve it out holy [__]
yeah well I don't know man is he able to
fight yeah he'll still fight no oh my
God that's [__] up dude what do they
do they carve it out
yeah must have been really really bad
Jesus
Christ that's just dirty mats just
rubbing who knows staff's everywhere
everywh if he gets in your joints
apparently it's really bad well if he
gets in your bloodstream is when it's
bad that's when you're [__] did mer
yeah horrible is that it chin that's it
wow [__] well Brian you're off to a
wedding I am buddy but uh I'll be at
I'll be at the shamberg Improv October
27th and 28th I got to get that up on on
there shamber impov October 27 28 Friday
Saturday Raleigh North Carolina good
nights November 9 10 and 11 and yuck
yucks Calgary November 16 17 when you
talk to your agent do you go can you
send me as far as possible yeah I try to
get really out there I will be in
Niagara Falls November 4th and 5th those
are almost sold out one show Friday one
show Saturday November 4th and 5th
Niagara Falls New York at senica casino
that's not far yeah oh oh oh but I have
to go to the Olympia for rain on the
night before so I got to fly to Orlando
Oh you go from Orlando fly into Buffalo
and then take a car to niag damn right
you will uh then I'm in Chicago December
8th and 9th two shows Friday two shows
Saturday Chicago come get you some uh
Niagara follows you up next on November
4th through the 5th new pod with uh we
did live at skankfest in Vegas with the
Legion of skanks and Brian I is
available right now bonus episode a
firing kid with Legion of skanks Lewis
Gomez Dave Smith Big Jay Brian C myself
available right now on YouTube all audio
platforms all right kids love you we're
out